hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from the under 16 World
youth Championship that happened
yesterday it's from round eight and it
is rajer marara representing France and
Bennett hagna representing Germany uh
it's a brilliant game uh I know we've
we've really been spoiled lately with
all these amazing sacrifices and amazing
games but um seems the show goes on uh
and uh well here's another one so let's
check it out rajet has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to C4 so starting
off with an English opening uh Knight to
F6 we have Knight to F3 and now E6 the
ainur defense to the English but now
Pawn to G3 and pawn to D5 um transposing
to the Kings Indian the Yugoslav
variation and now Pawn to D4 transposing
into the Catlin opening and now Bishop
to B4 with check so here Roger waited a
bit with the the advancement of the D
Pawn so black cannot play Bishop to B4
right away but now he did play it and
Bishop to B4 check is a very very
popular option here that allows black to
uh well sort of equalize very very early
on so Bishop to D2 We have Bishop back
to E7 and now Bishop to G2 we have Pawn
uh sorry Bishop to G2 we have Pawn to C6
and now Queen to C2 so all very standard
stuff everything been played before
Knight bd7 we have castles and now
Knight to E4 putting pressure on the
bishop on D2 and white very happily
gives up the bishop pair here with
Knight to C3 Knight captures Knight
captures and now King side cap castles
we have Rook a to D1 and now there are a
couple of games that read this position
for example F5 is a known move here
Knight to F6 is a known move here Bishop
to F6 is a know move here but here we
have Rook to B8 by Bennett and it is now
as of move 11 that we have a completely
new game uh so okay Pawn to E4 striking
in the center D captures on e4 Knight D
captures on e4 and now only Now Pawn to
F5 chasing away the Knight Knight back
to D2 and now Pawn to E5 now the pawn
was very weak on E6 but now that it's on
E5 you can trade in the center or you
can advance at the E4 it becomes very
strong so Pawn to D5 and now Pawn to E4
now this is um a double-edged idea uh
whenever you see something like this yes
you do uh gain more space you gain
control of D3 and F3 but you lose
control over the squares that the pawn
controlled when it was on E5 and those
are the D4 and F4 squares so now this
gives white an idea let's REM maneuver
our Knight to e for World it will be
very strong will have access to E6 and
so on so Queen to E8 and now Rook F to
E1 nicely aligning The Rook with the
queen here so Queen to G6 and now Knight
to D4 now the Knight is eyeing that E6
Square so Knight to E5 so the bishop
defends it and now we have Pawn to F4
chasing away the Knight and the Knight
gets a very nice Square here on the on
D3 if you go captures alasan then just
Rook captures on E5 and the bishop is
also undefended White would just win on
material here so you have to play Knight
to D3 which is what of course black
wanted and now uh you could try moving
The Rook but it doesn't really end well
leaving the Knight here this Knight on
D3 is now more powerful than the Rook
this is not make no mistake this is a
monster Knight so of course rajot uh
eliminates it and sacrifices The
Exchange Rook captures on D3 e captures
Queen captures and now Bishop to
C5 uh pinning the Knight as the king is
on G1 King to H1 and now Rook to E8
offering a rook trade which um of course
is accepted captures captures and now uh
you don't want to allow Queen to E1
check so Knight to C2 now the Knight
guards the E1 Square Bishop to D7 and
now we have Pawn to B4 starting the
advancement uh very often the strongest
move in any position we have Bishop to
f8 and now Pawn to C5 advancing the pawn
and now preparing Pawn to D6 to create a
very strong pass Pawn so Pawn to a A5
attacking the base of the pawn chain and
now Pawn to A3 making this the base of
the pawn chain a captures a captures and
now the position is a most delicate one
and you should play C captures on D5 for
example C captures now you don't want to
play Queen capture you could play Queen
capts with check but it's not all that
impressive after the king moves the
queen just takes away the D5 Square from
the Knight and the Knight really belongs
there and if you play this uh then you
will uh still you can still move the
king but the bishop will come to C6 to
counter white strong light Square Bishop
uh we often say when we analyze games
that start off as a Catan the the Catlin
Bishop is usually the strongest piece on
the board often times even stronger than
the queen but here you have nice control
over C6 and B5 and this is how you
should play it however after a captures
on B4 uh B6 was played by Bennett and
now now he just allows this Pawn to B5
move that um allows white to create a
very very strong pass Pawn so C captures
on D5 was played but now Pawn to C6 the
ADV advancement that would not be
possible uh in the line that we've shown
Bishop to E6 and now comes Knight to D4
uh you could also just capture on D5
right away but he has a different idea
Knight to D4 uh Bishop to F7 and now we
have Bishop captures on D5 now you don't
have to trade now you can play Rook to
d8 as it was played in the game Knight
captures on F5 and now Bishop captures
on D5 with check Knight captures on D5
and now Bishop to C5 and this is where
the magic happens there are two ways you
could play this um and still emerge
Victorious one is Pawn to C7 which I'm
sure some of you would uh go for uh and
then maybe improve the position of your
king you know slow play the position but
no uh rajet had a different idea he
played Knight to H6 with check and now
uh what's the what's the reason for this
move can you just uh capture the Knight
well not really if you capture the
Knight to F6 check Forks the king and
the Queen and once you move the king now
comes Knight captures an E8 and yes you
can also capture uh the White Queen but
now Pawn to C7 and as you have a dark
Square bishop and The Rook cannot go to
C uh to d8 to cover the C8 Square white
will just bring a Queen into the game on
the next move so that's the problem
after Knight to H6 with accepting the
Knight so King the h8 was played and now
comes the real shocker of The Possession
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for rajot while I give you a couple
of seconds there is only one winning
move here and it's a most Spectacular
One
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always finding
new excellent ways to sacrifice your
queen and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Knight to F6 and
now look at this position I mean really
soak it in uh what what is happening
here is is is such a thing even possible
can can't we just capture the queen or
even better can we move our Queen let's
say queen E1 check let's say King G G2
and now take the queen well no because
now Knight to F7 is Checkmate the Knight
covers the G8 square and this Knight
delivers Checkmate so that's why that
will not be happening another thing
after this King to h8 move and Knight to
F6 uh okay we can't move the queen but
can we at least trade queens and give up
our own Queen we're still up the
exchange not really because after Knight
captures you end up with the same idea
of uh this Pawn just being Unstoppable
there there's no way to do it if you
capture the Knight C s and again The
Rook cannot go back the the bishop
cannot help out as it's a dark Square
Bishop C8 is a light Square you cannot
go to the cile as the bishop is
preventing you and you can give a few
checks but the king easily hides and
that's it you play C8 and win the game
uh so after this Knight captures an E8
move uh well basically the game could
have been resigned on Knight to F6 but
they continue a few more moves Rook to
C3 was played uh and now uh just Pawn to
C7 the bishop now has to move in order
for The Rook to defend the queening
square so Bishop to A3 but now the the
other Knight comes into the game Knight
F7 check King to G8 and now Knight to E5
the real idea of course is that if the
King goes um near the Knight you will
just block The Rook with Knight to C6
and you will advance the pawn to C8
promoting it to a queen so after Knight
E5 Bishop to D6 was played and now
Knight captures on D6 you have to give
up the bishop in order to win that pawn
Rook captures on C7 and now KN e to C4
and he was in this position on move 42
that benett hna resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
truly an incredible game U only 42 moves
but what what an amazing Queen sacrifice
like I said we we are spoiled for Choice
when when choosing games to cover with
so many uh so many queens being offered
lately uh but yeah for those of you who
are maybe new to chess and don't feel
that this is maybe enough to win the
game or maybe black could play on
there's nothing nothing for black to try
here point is that once you you cannot
capture the knights the knights are
defending each other so The Rook is I
mean useless here you can't even go
after the pawn as the the Knight defends
the pawn so you could get the king into
the game but now you're just going to
start capturing Knight captures on B6
and now okay you can give a few checks
Knight C1 check King G2 Rook to B1
attack the pawn uh but the Knight just
moves and now you have this square is
defended this square is defended you can
push it all the way to B7 let's say King
goes here you push the pawn all the way
to B7 and that's pretty much it now the
king and Rook are stuck here guarding
the the pawn and knights and the white
king will just you know uh March up the
board start advancing the pawns and win
the game or even if you black starts
preventing that for example with
something like G6 um and H6 now you will
go after the pawn you will give up the
B7 pawn and after some trades happen
here you will pick up this Pawn as well
and now you have three pawns and two
knights for a rook uh that of course
even your uncle could easily win this uh
but yeah let's check out this move one
more time after King to h8 Knight to F6
what what a spectacular move uh the
reason I didn't use this on the
thumbnail rather I used the hypothetical
position that did not happen on the
board is because I would ruin the POS
the video moment so hopefully you guys
can understand that uh but yeah once
again really hope you enjoyed it I would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
Luke happy belated birthday as his
birthday was two days ago and I would
like to thank Ahmed alhabi David
Sashu and the desert sand software for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it and I
would also like to wish a happy first
wedding anniversary to Aaron Matthew I
hope it was a good one uh and that it
continues to be so and as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions such as this
one and whatever else happens in the
Chess World uh thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day